In 1860 in Pembrokeshire, Wales someone spouted
the phrase, "Eat an apple on going to bed,
and you’ll keep the doctor from earning
his bread."
An apple a day keeps the doctor away!
But will it, REALLY?
Apples are native to central Eurasia -- what
is now Kazakhstan and have been spread across
the world by traders and travelers over the
centuries.
1,500 years ago, apples appeared in Ayurvedic
medicine -- an ancient holistics practice
-- and apples were thought of as healthful
by the ancient Anglo-Saxon and Roman societies.
"An apple a day sends the doctor away" was
first used in 1922, and unsurprisingly, it's
stuck around!
Also unsurprisingly, since people say it all
the time, science studied it, and apples ARE
healthful!
Eating an apple every day could prevent 8,500
vascular-related deaths in people over 50,
according to the British Medical Journal.
A 2011 study from the Journal of the American
Heart Association found people who ate "white"
fruits and vegetables -- apples and pears,
for example -- had a 52 percent lower incidence
of stroke and heart attack.
So what is it about apples?
Are they some kind of miracle fruit?
I mean, not the actual miracle fruit that
makes things taste funny -- but like, a specially
healthful one?
Apples contain the following building blocks
as broken down by HowStuffWorks: Pectin: you
may have seen this on some processed labels,
apples contain them naturally, it's a form
of fiber related to reducing blood pressure,
LDL and glucose levels.
Boron: which supports healthy bones and brains.
Quercetin (qwar-sehtin): is a flavonoid which
may reduce damage from free radicals -- atoms
in the body with unpaired electrons which
can damage cells.
Free radicals can damage DNA, so reducing
them has been linked to lower risks of cancers,
Alzheimer's and age-related problems.
Vitamin C, A, E, and beta carotene which also
fight free radicals, boost immune response,
reduce risk of heart disease, asthma, and
diabetes.
Guys, all that sounds pretty frickin' AWESOME
TO ME.
And that's not ALL.
According to the Institute of Food Research,
apples also contain polyphenols, can block
a protein receptor called VEGF, which helps
cancer progression in the body!
Polyphenols are found naturally in fruits,
vegetables, and other things like green tea!
But the thing is, apples aren't alone in these
properties.
Pears contain a lot of the same nutrients,
in fact -- so do MANY fruits and berries.
Compounds in cranberries and blueberries fight
urinary tract infections, blackberries and
strawberries have fiber, bananas have potassium:
which boosts heart and muscle function.
They ALL have a lot of fructose though, which
in large quantities ISN'T great…
If you ate only apples, you'd become severely
malnourished; no one thing can sustain the
human body -- we need a variety of things.
An apple (or pear or other fruit or vegetable)
may keep the doctor away, but it's not going
to do it alone.
Do you eat apples?
Do you even LIKE apples?
What's your favorite fruit?
I WANT TO KNOW.
I used to like apples.
I think I ate too many.
TELL ME IN THE COMMENTS.
And if you're like me, you're worried what
will happen to all our food if nuclear war
happens, or climate change devastates the
planet -- I worry about stuff, guys -- but
my friend Evan over on Seeker explored the
Svalbard Seed Vault -- Humanity's last best
hope -- for a tasty future.Thanks
for watchin' DNews y'all!
Subscribe.
Like.
Share.
Love.
Hugs.
Eat.
See ya.